[Applaudissements]
louise portal pour vos cinquante ans de
carrière vous recevez tout un cadeau
c'est le plus triste du gala québec
cinéma alors comment vous vu ce grand
moment là avec beaucoup de gratitude
évidemment parce que ça marque une étape
1 c'est je me retire doucement sur la
pointe des pieds là quand même après 50
ans de cinéma je renvoie 72 ans c'est
que ça permet de faire un bilan puis de
regarder en arrière puis là tout à coup
je reçois ce qui va avoir dans le
programme plongée regardant ou tel film
m'ont déjà vous oblige avait fait tel
film adam il ya sayah s'appuie là ça
c'est plein de souvenirs qui remontent
des belles rencontres vraiment des
cadeaux souvent des cadeaux vous parlez
de souvenirs de bilan remontons dans le
temps juste comme impies le tout petit
avec vous au sort vous faisais des
spectacles dans le garage ou sur le toit
du garage votre père était écrivain
jusqu'à quel point et vous avez
d'ailleurs publier vos correspondances
avec votre père oui jusqu'à quel point
votre part est responsable de louise
portal binger le nom de plume de mon
père moi je suis né là points et puis
porte à ces noms plume que le pape a
choisi en 1960 pour publié un premier
livre et j'ai compris mais beaucoup plus
tard qu'il y avait une grande influence
dans ma vie je ressens beaucoup
je fais des cahiers je fais des collages
papa était comme ça et entretenait des
correspondances avec beaucoup de monde
moi j'ai beaucoup de correspondances
j'ai écrit beaucoup de lettres d'amour
dans ma vie je corresponds avec ma grand
maman d'adoption cassant un an
maintenant
donc j'ai beaucoup de traits qui
ressemble à mon père
je veux parler d'un film qui vous a
marqué le corps des gardes de jean
beaudin où vous incarnez une femme et
son amant tous les deux jugé injustement
se retrouve en prison c'est une grande
injustice c'est un film qu'ils ont
marqué c'est sûr que quand d'iliad avait
un personnage
tellement
émouvant est tellement important pour
moi parce que quand des liasses une
histoire vraie et puis quand on incarne
un personnage qui a eu une vie qui avait
vraiment vibré pour le vrai c'est comme
si son âme venait nous nous visiter pour
qu'on puisse lui donner une chance de
s'incarner à l'écran alors en plus c'est
le lieu de ce trajet que j'étais super
bien entouré par une pléiade de
comédiens merveilleux et sous la
direction de jean beaudin scénario écrit
par marcel sabourin et j'en écoute c'est
comme quelque chose qui était à mon avis
je crois profondément et a inscrit dans
mon destin pigasse sont encore cordelia
une corde elle était liée à une corde
puis vont mourir pendu c'est parier je
pourrais faire tout en entrevue le
daily star long de votre dixième film et
j'ai nommé le déclin rappeur américain
votre personnage de diam's avait ouvert
les portes à l'international
ouais vraiment où et de quelle façon
comment ça se passe mais écoutez
c'est un film qui a fait le tour du
monde alors moi ça a été mon passeport
sont venus me chercher j'ai fait des
beaux projets mais je me serais pas vu
faire une carrière internationale ou
même une carrière en france a passé
proche la tue c'est sûr qu'en 80,2 quand
je tourne des fauves je fais la première
partie maxime de foresti à bobino
mais l'exil n'était pas pour moi pour
croire puis je regrette rien parce que
là où je suis maintenant aujourd'hui
c'est exactement la place où je suis
heureuse d'être dans ma vie
professionnelle et ma vie personnelle en
préparant cet entretien ce qui me
fascine c'est que vous êtes vraiment une
artiste multiforme en télévision cinéma
des livres de la musique aussi
brillé absolue plusieurs choses plus
facilement à vis de vous vous devez
boire est lui carrément alors comment
vous voyez ça justement vieillir louise
portal mais j'aime mieux parler d'abord
dû vieillir parce que pour moi c'est pas
la même chose que vieille sbs est
entachée de beaucoup de costumes en nous
et que je préjugés le vieillir c'est
accepter qu'on est con à tout ce bagage
et puis qu'on continue d'avancer comme
moi je comprends pas ça le talent d
actrice qu'il faut qu'il se fasse
refaire picchi qui va qui refuse de
vieillir je comprends pas ça parce que
pour moi est une actrice c'est justement
c'est se mettre au service
d'une incarnation dans le fonds de
prêter tout son être à une incarnation
son cas son âme sa sensibilité ses
défauts ses qualités et on est chanceuse
parce que si tu fais pas ça dans la
création du russe cas de le faire dans
la vie de vos impôts d'euros
à part que ce marconnet sport
louise portal merci pour cette belle
rencontre bienvenue